this is a really nice moment Marjorie
Taylor green going after leswell not
even going after Leslie Saul she's just
laying out the truth here on CBS and
that doesn't happen very often so Leslie
Stahl has nothing to say things she says
that are over the top like the Democrats
are a party of pedophiles
I would definitely say so they support
grooming children they are not
pedophiles why would you say that
Democrats Democrats support even Joe
Biden the president himself supports
children being sexualized and having
transgender surgeries sexualizing
children is what pedophiles do to
children
wow
okay
okay because it is true when you
sexualize children that is what
pedophiles do I'm pretty sure it's baked
in there and the definition of the thing
and why is it that to get us to where we
started today that they want drag queens
who until five years ago were only at
late night clubs did you watch the bird
cage remember the bird cage great movie
20 something years ago Robin Williams
remember that do you think they had kids
in the audience and if they did everyone
would think it was ridiculous but Leslie
stall doesn't know what to say she says
these evil things and then it's like
yeah it's all kind of true
[Music]
foreign